imagine a city where you'd be happy to
live a city that's not too different
from many others
a place where people live in smaller and
bigger communities they belong to
families Circles of friends working in
school communities neighborhoods all
connected to each other by their regular
activities
these activities whether they're Hobbies
or responsibilities need energy
but where does this energy come from for
supplying this need people utilize a
wide range of energy sources
however these sources are not always
environmentally friendly producing and
consuming energy often results in the
emission of carbon dioxide and other
greenhouse gases
this has a negative impact on the city's
climate and consequently on citizens
lives when we look closer some
households are more efficient in
managing their energy consumption
total energy requirements may be
different from household to household
due to many factors but we all have room
for improvement when it comes to bad
practices of excess usage and energy
waste
to limit the impact of climate change
leaders have decided to take action to
try and reduce the emission of
greenhouse gases
they have decided to introduce a trading
system which creates a financial
incentive for households to reduce their
emissions the system works like this
first they set a monthly limit per
household for the emission of greenhouse
gases which will be monitored on a
regular basis
each household then needs to pay for the
emissions from their monthly carbon
emission allowance for the sake of
Simplicity let's call these carbon
credits if one of the households decides
they want to reduce their emissions
through installing solar panels buying
more energy efficient appliances
switching to biomass energy sources or
other alternative solutions they might
have some carbon credits remaining at
the end of the month they can then sell
their remaining carbon credits to
households that are about to exceed the
limits and need more if a household
doesn't have enough credits to cover
their emissions that month they will
then pay a special tax which will be
reinvested by the city to support
Innovative eco-friendly Solutions
further reducing the negative impacts of
the city's emissions over time carbon
credit allowances are reduced as more
households reduce their emissions and
switch to cleaner energy sources
whilst this city is fictional the system
is not in 2005 the European Union
established the emissions trading system
instead of limiting household emissions
the system limits emissions from the
power sector manufacturing Industries
and Airlines operating in the EU
countries as well as Iceland
Liechtenstein and Norway to find out
more click the link in the description
[Music]